foreign
well hey you guys what's going on yeah
it's Sunday and we're back again new
lighting we survived
oh [__] holy [__] dude holy [__] stop it
what's funny is this one
I couldn't turn the volume down because
I was getting a damn notification of
something on [__] man you got you've
got all kind of problems [__] up yeah
that's the story of my life right yeah
uh Anthony says Periwinkle yeah that's
definitely the color that uh of the
Caravan that they wanted but yeah so uh
xanadas here so that's good yeah uh
because xanada is the one that sent us
this movie as well as the last one Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels so as I
said this was Guy Ritchie's second film
after Lock Stock and Brad Pitt ended up
being in this because after Lock Stock
came out Brad Pitt called guy Richie up
and said hey whatever your next movie is
I want to be in it so they let him be in
it and Brad Pitt I mean
he's good in it he's really good he's
[__] iconic I kind of feel like this
I saw this movie in the theater this
came out in 2000 and I saw this in the
theater when it came out and I remember
really liking it like I remember it
being really funny I hadn't seen it
again since then so I had forgotten like
a lot of the crazy plot twists and
everything but I think Brad Pitt made
probably the largest impression like on
a lot of people just because of his
crazy accent which was kind of
sounded like an Irish accent but I mean
it wasn't supposed to sound exactly like
an Irish accent because he's supposed to
be an Irish traveler kind of person
so yeah so they don't they don't sound
exactly like Irish so and also part of
the joke too was that he was supposed to
be kind of mush-mouther like nobody knew
what he was saying so I think that was
kind of like part of the joke
Zayna said I only saw this once but I
remember liking it a lot I'm also a huge
Benicio del Toro fan he's a great actor
yeah I love him too he's awesome and to
be honest I had forgotten how
not in this much he is like what because
the cast of this is so huge and there's
like a bunch of different groups of
people like kind of all doing things up
you know at the same time and so he's
just like one little Cog in this whole
like machine of what's going on so he's
really only in it in the beginning
because spoiler alert he gets killed
like probably not even like halfway
through the movie right because he gets
shot by like the Russian dude but uh but
yeah uh Xander said light looks good
yeah we've got new um we got a new ring
light and stuff we're mostly we're using
it for the other project but I said well
I'm gonna throw it over here and see
what it looks like and because I can't I
want to get another ring light that we
can like do lower down because it's kind
of like high up you know what I mean
because I'm telling you like a lot of
the photos and [__] like that that I
took yesterday with the ring light I was
like holy crap I was like I need to get
a ring light that I can just like carry
around with me all the time to like
shine on my face because I was like ooh
that soft pink light I was like look how
[__] Angelic I look it's like I don't
even look like me anymore I'm like
that's pretty awesome I need one yeah
here's an example I need one of those to
like carry around with me yeah that's
that's an example of of how that ring my
[__]
yeah you're extremely flattering oh it's
all the damn yeah very flattering yeah
so I was like oh now I know why
everybody buys those yeah
because like all the pictures came out
I'm like holy crap I look like a [__]
child I really I really need to like uh
yeah so it was like she passed for 20.
that's what I mean it's like it's not in
in real life I can't but it's like yeah
and then photos with like your photos
with that no no no people some people
thought you're in your 30s yeah how
about people think I was in my like
mid-30s but yeah
in real life but yeah not not so much
not so much 20. no way uh but yeah Tammy
says new wig looks really good yes this
is a new one this is one of the ones
that I got from uh from Sheehan yeah and
it's got gray in it yeah I kind of dug
it I was just kind of like I kind of
like the yeah it looks good it's kind of
like hot old lady energy she's got a mom
wig too a little well that was that was
in that picture that was in my picture
she looks good in it I said I get a
scene in it it looks good I said it
looks like Mom hair but I was like he's
like but not in a bad way yeah yeah that
was the idea yeah well you know hot mom
hair in that in in that particular genre
it's A Woman's Gotta if she if she's
working alone or mostly alone I'm in it
um she has to be multiple characters and
that is it's like [__] cosplay if not
the channel gets boring that's everybody
else does it and that's that's the best
way to do it yes we're like farting
around with different ways yeah you're
not always yourself you're gonna be
somebody else
yesterday if you saw that picture like I
had blue contacts then too yeah because
you got blue contacts because my eyes
are not blue I'm gonna get a gonna get a
uh that particular company you can buy
contacts in a sets of 10 and get a real
good deal I'm gonna do that
Chesney's random and useless collection
of things says very bright of
Frankenstein letting her hair down yeah
see I like that too I like that too all
right so uh we only just now finished
watching snatch like literally like half
an hour ago because we didn't have time
we were shooting some stuff last night
normally we'd watch the movies on
Saturday night and then you know give me
time to like research them and stuff the
next day but we didn't have time last
night because we were
you know shooting a scene and it went
like way over and so we didn't have time
to watch it because we weren't done till
like 11 or 12. and then
um then I had a bunch of other [__] I
had to do today so we didn't get to
watch the movie until
like literally a couple of hours ago so
we only just finished watching it like
literally half an hour it's a good movie
yeah um did we I I think I like this one
slightly better than Lock Stock they're
very similar yeah they're similar I mean
they don't have it's not the same plot
really but I mean it's kind of like the
same setup where you have like all of
these
seemingly disparate uh groups of
criminals like all doing their own
little [__] and then it all like
intertwines and then like ends up being
like a big thing in the end and so in
that sense it is very similar and again
I kind of feel like
if you weren't paying attention just
kind of like in Lock Stock it's hard to
keep track of everything because it's a
very large cast and it's kind of like a
very I don't think it's I don't know I
don't know if I'd say it's that
complicated there's really just kind of
like two main plots going on right
there's just like the diamond like the
84 karat diamond or whatever it is
that's stolen so there's that whole
thing and then and everybody trying to
get hold of that and then there's the
whole
uh boxing promoter thing going on and
then like at the end and some of the
people like are involved in both things
but they then it kind of just like ties
up at the end you know what I'm saying
yeah I keep getting kicked off the
internet is that thing running
no no it's not pretty okay no not me
it's not doing anything it was running a
while ago uh xanadas said be honest was
it good I haven't seen this one in years
so I was kind of shooting in the dark
when I sent it yeah I actually um I like
this one a little bit better than
because I found the um the crime some of
the gags were funnier
um and I kind of feel like
um I kind of felt I liked the whole like
uh undercover like underground boxing
thing and the whole Diamond thing like I
I liked those a lot better than the
crime at the that they did in Lock Stock
but they're both really good I mean
they're both like I said really similar
but you know they're shot the same in
that kind of like crazy
uh you know real kinetic style like he
would do which was really like
influential but I think a lot of when
this came out I feel like a lot of
critics complained because they're like
oh well it's just like Lock Stock and
Two Smoking Barrels which like I said it
is but
I'm I'm not mad at it I'm just well it's
just because like Lock Stock was good
and it's like that's the kind of movies
that he likes to make he likes to make
like crime based dark comedies he's
doing the same thing Tarantino was doing
right and it's like you know no one
really pissed him on about well they
probably did piss and more about them
a director and you know they was doing
his own style and it was gags for stuff
and you know
Tarantino was doing the same thing but
they have very different styles of the
two
not very different they're different
though yeah the tones are very different
yeah I mean I do kind of feel like a lot
of times Guy Ritchie kind of gets called
oh like the British Tarantino which I
guess is true like in a very shallow
sense in the you know like I said in the
sense that they're making kind of like
crime caper movies that are like dark
comedies with a bunch of interconnected
yeah plot lines and it's kind of a Pulp
Fiction type right like I get that but
other than that like you said tonally
it's very different they're very British
which is what I like about them
um and I think I like because some of
the same actors and it's like Jason
Statham is in this one too
um Vinnie Jones is in this one too and I
actually think I like Vinnie Jones
character a bit better in this one just
because he doesn't get as much screen
time as he does in Lock Stock but I just
really liked a couple of scenes that
he's in especially that scene um toward
the end where he's confronting the two
uh kind of small time hoods or like
Lenny James and the other guy where you
know they have like the fake pistols and
he sees that they're like replicas on
the side and he's like all intimidating
and stuff and I love that his teeth are
like bullets because that was kind of
his whole thing was he got [__] those
those are like the there's his Bullet
Tooth Tony or whatever his name was like
everybody has cool names like that you
know what I mean like Jason Statham's
character is called Turkish because he
says at the beginning it was like named
after
a plane crash right like somebody's in a
plane crash and he was named after the
airline which was like Turkish Airlines
so he got named after that and then
everybody has names like [__] uh yeah
like Bullet Tooth Tony and [__]
Frankie four fingers that's Benicio del
Toro's character because he's like a
gambler and I guess he kept like losing
a bunch of money so like he would lose
money and like they would cut his
fingers off like for punishment and [__]
like that yeah and in the tradition of
his other movie okay and a lot of the
British case moves that I've seen the
gangsters the characters don't know
anything about guns uh they say [__]
crazy [__] about guns it isn't true they
admit to not knowing about gods they
don't know how to practice with him
um
they uh if you were if all you knew
about God so you were learning from
British gangster movies you wouldn't
know anything
but there are some cool guns in it I
know I got Gun Guys in the audience
um
they had a spouse 12 shotgun that had
been cut down with a [__] short and
[__] magazine tube underneath it
and it looks wicked as [__] uh just a
famous shotgun from the 80s
same one [__] the Terminator was used
and then Terminator one you could shoot
at the police station
then look that shotgun looked mean as
[__] there wasn't much to it though
really you know
nothing compared to say something
magazine fed like a Saiga 12
um it was just kind of wicked looking I
think the thick in in the version that
they showed couldn't have carried
anymore in five rounds
um
main bad guy there uh has a desert eagle
50.
yeah Bullet Tooth Tony yeah bulletin
Tony which I fired him in 357 Magnum I
fired them in 44 magnum and I fired them
in 50. and he shoots that 50 in this in
this
in this uh movie
of course it's blank firing you know
it's not the real thing but uh he rapid
fires it like it's nine millimeter and
if if you've ever shot what a [__]
Desert Eagle 50s like no it's [__]
Wicked uh it's not something you could
rapid fire
the 44 magnum is about like shooting a
[__] 19 11 45 even that's kind of
tough the rabbit fire but you know
[__] 50s like even more of a [__]
boom boom you know [__] slow a lot of
high kind of high recoil but soft and
long takes place over a long time
um
they had some interesting uh they had an
interesting [__] HK it looked like an
hkp7 might have been the p14 but it's
hard to tell
and uh some kind of a stire I think I
think it was I think that was a stire GB
I think is what they called it which was
and in this movie it turns out that they
were actually blank firing replicas yeah
they didn't they weren't the real thing
they didn't have that was how they got
hold on because like I said the two guys
they were kind of like small time hoods
and they worked at a pawn shop and they
were in over their heads yeah I don't
know of any black firing replicas maybe
Japan made something like that I mean
they made replicas of just everything
things that we what's funny is that in
America you can get those guns that's
all legal and easy to get
as long as you're not a felon you pass a
background check you can get it you
could never sell a replica like that
though uh-uh not here in the United
States this is that's too close to the
real thing and they don't want people
[__] walking around with something
like that you'll get shot you know
um that matter of fact there were some
replica AR-15s that were I think they
were
um some kind of a uh paintball not
paintball what do you call it Airsoft
yeah uh an airsoft AR-15s and they
wouldn't let them in
because the lower receiver which is the
bottom part of the gun that carries all
the trigger Parts was an exact replica
so here you could just put the full auto
parts in it and there's your full auto
machine gun because we have the real
uppers and lowers and everything else to
activate that it was the correct
aluminum and it was the exact correct
shape it would accept full auto parts
so they wouldn't let that in and that
was some from Japan
because they don't have guns over there
so they're not worried about somebody
activating something you know over here
you can activate
over here you can get machine guns
legally too so it's not really a big
deal most people aren't really that
interested in them because it
why and how machine guns or full Autos
work they're not that attractive really
they're full auto selector switches on
Military Firearms really only exist
because the semi-auto trigger is so
shitty you can't pull it very quickly so
you flip it over to a full auto
selection and it'll pull a trigger for
you
um but you can now drop in semi-auto
triggers that are so sweet you can pull
that trigger just about as fast as a
machine gun can fire
um but
British Flick's always kind of [__]
tripped me out with the [__] that the
characters say about guns it's just
whoever's right and doesn't know the
[__] they're talking about well the
thing too is that a lot of the joke of
guy Ritchie's movies is that these are
criminals that don't and it's a black
comedy they don't really know what
they're doing and they don't really so a
lot of the humor kind of comes from
their cluelessness yeah although I will
say one of my favorite like and it's and
they don't even
um like lean too hard into this but this
just like made me laugh was the scene
toward the end where Bullet Tooth Tony
where there's that big confrontation
like in that hallway and bullet Two
Tony's like shooting everybody with that
Desert Eagle yeah and he shoots Boris
the blade like the Russian guy and they
had made and they didn't reference this
like later on in the movie so they were
counting on you to remember but earlier
on in the movie like way near the
beginning they were talking about Boris
the blade and it's like how like it was
impossible to kill him or something like
that so like at the end when when Bullet
Tooth Tony is like shooting him and he's
like off screen but he's like shooting
at him and it's like he shoot him and
then there's like a couple seconds of
quiet and then you're here Boris like
say something and then he just keeps
like [__] shooting him and he won't
[__] die and it's like and they don't
show Boris which makes it funnier to me
like it's just like a couple seconds of
silence and he's like and then he'll say
something crazy like he's not dead yet
and then he's like would you just die
and it's like that just made me laugh
because it's like they like I said they
didn't reference that they referenced
that one time like towards the beginning
of the movie that he was like impossible
to kill and I thought there are there
you know the whole Desert Eagle angle
that she's talking about there that is
on the American side of of the audience
watching that especially the action side
the guys that like action movies there's
kind of a joke about the desert eagle
the Desert Eagle was a fine pistol all
right it was big it was Heavy it wasn't
something you could really conceal
it came out of the 70s in Israel where
they were trying to make a police pistol
like a fire three to seven Magnum that
was semi-auto that had no recoil that
their female officers could carry and it
did that all right
it was big light recoiling in 57 you
could rapid fire it it was great really
and it kind of made sense in that
caliber
but when Hollywood got a hold of that
pistol especially when it became 44
Magnum
that thing was in every [__] action
movie it became a meme yeah uh the the
[__] Desert Eagle is the mullet of
[__] pistols all right that's a good
yes the mullet of pistols that's that's
that's the analogy that's a good analogy
everybody [__] every movie had that
thing in it yeah and they weren't cheap
though I'm not saying they were cheap
it's just that they were
stereotypical you know they were they
were they were a meme it was they were
meme cannons that's what they were a man
Cannon they were a meme cannon fire off
the memes fire out is the mean candid
that's what it was
uh they were good though but like you
said it seemed like guy Richie knew that
and yeah like that's why he specifically
made that like kind of like a little bit
of a PowerPoint that would be the last
thing you'd want to carry in combat as a
[__] Desert Eagle 50. that same
weight you could carry an AR-15 carrying
30 rounds
you can't conceal either one so why it's
outside the Rage of a pistol so you
might as well just make it a rifle that
thing's [__] huge if I couldn't
conceal that and that's all pistols are
for it's concealment if you can't
conceal it
so you know it's good for haunting
though uh and the Israelis didn't care
about concealment because it was going
to ride in a holster for a policeman you
know but uh in the U.S some places like
here in Florida you can you got
constitutional carry you know everyone
has a right to carry a weapon here but
not in the open it's got to be concealed
they don't want people on The Hip
walking around other states is exactly
the reverse it just depends on
how people interpret the safety you know
that you couldn't you can't consider it
you can't conceal a [__] Desert Eagle
it's heavy Santa said the desert Eagles
are always gold-plated in the movies
yeah yeah it's like and then Tyler the
guy said uh the video game character
Duke Nukem uh who was the satire of 80s
action heroes and his signature weapon
was a big ass golden Desert Eagle yeah
yeah that's why yeah that's what we were
talking about like that it almost became
like a cliche like in action movies
which like I said is why they probably
put it in this movie and the mullet of
submachine guns is a tech nine like at a
big Big Trouble in Little China you see
Tech Nines everywhere and the American
ones were all [__] semi-auto but the
original one was the kg I think it was
called a kg 99 or Intertech 99 I think
is what it was called originally it's
some Swiss [__] company it was full
auto
but we didn't have them here they don't
think they ever imported any of them
good thing the bolts cracked on them
they did they weren't really made to
last
but yeah um but Bullet Tooth Tony's
character is great I mean Jason
Statham's character is great I have all
the characters are really good like are
really interesting I love also that they
have Dennis Farina in this who um I mean
he was in a [__] ton of stuff but
remember he did Unsolved Mysteries for a
while like after uh Robert Stack died
you remember he was like the thing of
that and he's just playing this kind of
like
um he's like a Jewish gangster he was
the one that um is comes to London to
get the to get the diamond and it's like
so that's a whole funny thing like a
whole funny like culture Clash type of
thing because he's just like this mouthy
New Yorker and he comes to England and
he just can't stand anything it's like I
thought you guys invented this language
and you don't even speak it because he
didn't know he doesn't know like any of
their slang or anything like that
because he says something got blacked
and he's like what the [__] does that
mean
um and yeah and I was gonna say like
Brad Pitt is [__] great in this too
he got like pretty ripped for this I
think that he trained as a bare knuckle
boxer
for the specific movie because that's
what he is in the thing although nobody
knows that until later on they call him
what like Mickey one punch O'Neil or
something like that where he just like
knocks everybody out like with one
[__] team and uh he
he did good in this movie and he was he
was looking great he looked real good
he's probably at the best of his
conditioning I think yeah although Fight
Club he was pretty [__] cut too well
Fight Club did that come out
uh the same year as the same year okay
maybe and now I can't remember like when
Fight Club came out if it was later than
this or yeah and don't feel bad if your
physique isn't like that he's not
natural all right that's
at least he's on I don't even think
that's anavar he's probably on mixer
Winstrol and angelone or something you
know he's uh
he's on [__]
but yeah we're running a testosterone
base and stuff but uh well yeah because
he had to get like in really good shape
for this movie because like I said he's
supposed to be like a bare knuckle boxer
and he was fighting dudes that were like
way bigger than him yeah uh that had
like a lot of weight on him so they had
to make him look like wiry and strong
enough that that was feasible that he
can like knock somebody out with one
punch yeah he's real wiry yeah well well
defined that's what I was thinking win
straw probably something like
testosterone and Winstrol Winstrol makes
you real wiry looking it's more for like
endurance Runners and it can really
increase definition a lot it's hard to
say what stack he was running but he was
running something he looked great and
looking back on it you know he was when
he was around I was young
all my friends were young and guys like
that guys like Brad Pitt they don't
stick out to y'all guys as we get older
and uglier we can we can see this guy
that goes man that was a good looking
guy I wish I look like that you know but
uh yeah he uh look seeing him now I can
understand why women liked him so much
he's he's a good looking guy yeah yeah
no he's not really my type but um but
I'm wild too he's kind of got a crazy
personality but I always like he's good
in like pretty much every movie that
he's in I mean he never that's one thing
he doesn't seem to like phone it in or
anything like that and he does take
interesting roles on yeah which like I
said I thought that was really cool that
he would actually be in this move this
like I said this is only guy Richie's
second movie so he was still kind of I
would see it wasn't like a nobody but he
wasn't like super famous and I love that
you know Brad Pitt who was like even a
huge star back then he like went out of
his way to call up this dude who had
just made one movie and said hey I
really liked your movie I'll be in your
next one yeah which is like pretty
amazing what's Nana just said about Brad
Pitt I agree I agree uh I didn't really
appreciate it about the time Glenn
reader yeah it says I didn't appreciate
Brad Pitt at the time now I think he's a
great uh actor great and now I think
he's great great actor too yeah he's I
really kind of I guess
um I know I've never really had like
anything against him necessarily like
the same way that I do like Tom Cruise
or something but um because honestly
don't don't get offended time
this Tom still loves you yeah but um I'm
another Tom in the short man Mafia oh by
the way if you weren't here on Friday
night
um where uh where Zach said we were
talking about Tom Hardy and Zach sent
Tom a picture of Tom Hardy that he had
posted on his Myspace from back in the
day where he's like he was like naked
but you could only see like his butt
really and he and his he had this
amazing back arch I was like [__] man I
just that looks like a contortionist
[__] right female porn star
it's an amazing photo it's from his
[__] Myspace page yeah from back in
the day like before he was super famous
he's nude laying down on Facebook
stomach down and next to him is a
[__] mirror and he's touching it and
he's on the sheets and [__] and his
[__] ass is arched up it's like
something it's incredible like the arch
is incredible I was just like that
doesn't even look real yeah it's that
looks like Photoshop yeah but um I was
like that's amazing I can't do that but
that's how he got his job in Hollywood
but I told him like we were talking
about that photo because we were talking
about Tom Hardy like the other like
yesterday morning or whatever and I said
oh my god do you know it would be
hilarious if we printed out that picture
well the first thing I said was I said
let's print out that picture and frame
it and put it over the bed and then take
a picture of it in its frame over the
bed and then send that to Zach like that
would be funny and then I was like let's
do that and then and then Tom's like oh
you know it would be even better than
that if we took up that picture and a
picture of Tom Cruise like in some kind
of sexy like either from Risky Business
or from Top Gun with a shirt off or
something like that and then put them on
either side and then put a picture of
Tom in the middle so it's like the three
Toms and then we'll hang that over the
bed and then I was like I was like we
gotta do do that that would be super
funny I don't know how long I'm gonna
leave it there but it was like if you're
just coming out with [__]
I don't know I just thought that was so
funny that Zach had sent you that
picture and I was like that is an
amazing picture right but it's funny
that Zach knew who he was back before he
was famous yeah I'm not real familiar
with Tom Hardy's very very early career
so I don't really know because it's my
space holy [__] that was a lot yeah I
guess the gay dudes were up on [__]
Tom Hardy before everybody else they had
advanced warning that's what I mean I
guess man they were like way out of the
curve on that one I'd mentioned this in
another in another program when we were
talking about uh Tom Hart some of Tom
Hardy in movies it was probably I think
I was probably when I was talking about
Legend
either that or uh
um the [__] which I kind of want to
see again actually about it Tom Hardy
picking it's hard to believe that he
played those characters and then he
ended up being Bane
and I heard you know that he was under a
lot of stress for Bane you know what I
mean because
Batman fans are like man he'll he could
never play babe
so he starts going on the juice and he
starts [__] and evidently he was like
crying he was having nervous [__]
attacks about trying to get big enough
to be [__] bad having the whole world
like [__] on you before you've even
like done it saying you can't do it like
that's pretty shitty so he goes on all
kinds of stuff you know I could kind of
imagine what stack he's on I've seen him
train when he was in the gym training
for it and um trying to put on as much
[__] weight as possible
and uh he did it pretty good I think I
think he did pretty good I think he did
get his bang now if you look at a
drawing from a cartoon like a a no man
could ever be those proportions you know
especially yeah it's a cartoon it's a
cartoon it's a drawing it's huge you
know and he's on Venom which is a
special
concoctions of steroids that he invented
himself
and he gets huge when he's on it
eventually he learns to
ways to stay that big while he's not on
it but you know [__] so the
characters on steroids
Mega steroids
and I just think it's [__] amazing
that you know Tom Hardy's commitment to
acting and commitment to I guess you say
self-development when you see where he
came from early photos of him
he was like a stereotypical pretty boy
yeah he was like a Macaulay Culkin type
well Tammy says he uh he won a modeling
competition yeah in his early days yeah
yeah and he seemed like he was very
slender very good looking and he's a
very good looking dude yeah he's gay
bait you know gay who's would [__]
loved that yeah exactly you know but you
look at him now he's [__] pretty big
you know yeah for a guy who's
didn't have some kind of special
[__] genetic gift for size you know
it was just at random and training and
[__] proper hormonal support and diet
and willpower you know you gotta he I
got a lot of respect for him he's a
great actor yeah yeah he's great in
everything yeah he's good man and he's
just got a lot of willpower you'd have
to have willpower to get that done so
big respect he really wanted that yeah
only other guy that only other actor
that has that amount of willpower been
Tom Cruise that guy's got willpower too
you might think he's a dick but he's
very skilled yeah I mean those are two
different things I've always said like
mad respect for as far as his career
he's like he's I don't think he's a
great actor actor but he actually does
he always gives like a thousand percent
right right right you know fly aircraft
and ride motorcycle yeah he can do it he
can do all his stunts and everything
like that I never [__] on him guns I
just think I just think he seems like an
[__] cruises cruises two different
things Cruz is good with guns too yeah
yeah
uh Zach says Tom Hardy's ass is
certainly big enough to play Bane all by
itself
all right
Zach says uh awesome hair Jen thank you
did you talk about the part yet where
the big black dude can't get out of the
car that's my favorite part yeah the big
black dude was at the table playing
cards with 007 and Casino Royale that's
right
I know I recognized him yeah I didn't
realize that he had speaking roles in
other movies I didn't know he was a
pretty famous British gangster actor
everybody in this like if you've seen a
lot of British films you will recognize
pretty much everybody in here because
it's like there he was that Scottish
dude that was in this that played uh was
this character's name mullet he was in
one scene that bullet head Tony like
pulled him in the car by his tie and
then like dragged him along like with
his head in the window like that dude
has been that dude was in Trainspotting
and he was in uh I think it was in some
Mike Lee movies I want to say but yeah
he's like and part of his thing too is I
think I'm pretty sure he's Scottish and
he has like a very very thick accent so
they always kind of like put him in
those kind of roles you know what I mean
I think my favorite part of this because
that is great I really like those three
guys together because and um Lenny James
like playing kind of like the I guess
he's sort of like the brains of the
operation or whatever and he's [__]
great in this he's Lenny James is great
and everything I love him and I feel
like you well you you had you saw him a
Walking Dead yeah and um he's great on
Walking Dead and I think he didn't
realize that he was British either
because he plays in America that's
another one you know I [__] I give
credit where credit's due man when it
comes to the theater the British [__]
got it at least if the language is
English it's gonna the British actors
are the best you know going all the way
back to the [__] William Shakespeare
man they they knew about theater they're
very good and they're real actors yeah
Hollywood actors uh yeah some of them
are into it some of them are into it for
like the craft yes of it and some of
them not so much some of them are into
it because of the casting couch and they
were good at parties and um you know
sleeping with the right people and
politics and yeah no because you know
even an average person you can give them
some training and make him a pretty good
actor get him through a Hollywood movie
they won't be like a [__]
Shakespearean thespian actor yeah
they're not gonna win anything they're
not gonna be that but you can get them
through action flick and that's where a
lot of them come from yeah because I
think a lot of them are just kind of
like well I just need to know enough
acting skills to like make millions of
dollars and then I'm happy do this part
where whereas you know you have people
like like you said like Tom Hardy or
well he's British but um or like
Christian Bale or somebody like that who
actually go the [__] extra mile and
like hey I'm gonna starve myself down to
80 pounds for this movie or hey I'm
gonna put on 300 pounds or Christian
Bale be the closest to the guys like
Hardy and all those Tom Cruise too but
yeah you have to be a little bit crazy I
feel but that's kind of true of any
creative Endeavor I kind of feel like
all the best people at it are a little
bit crazy Tom Cruise for financial
reasons he doesn't have a big rage he
has to stick within a certain kind of
role because that's where he's that's
his fans are going to respond to that
but I saw him in collateral is a [__]
villain he was great
great yeah he can do he can do a role
yeah it's just will he
because that might almost be a loss of
money for him yeah you know
um Zach says my other favorite part of
this movie is Alan Ford's accent Allen
Ford plays a great [__] he's bricktop
in this by the way he's a great I love
his whole big long thing about uh
feeding the people to the pigs like
cutting up the bodies and feeding him to
pigs and I love that he's just sitting
there very casually like talking about
it on the couch like while his Lackey
like brings him a cup of tea because of
course it's England so you have to have
everybody like bring you a cup of tea
even when you're talking about cutting
up bodies and feeding them to pigs I
think I I don't know I have a lot of
favorite bits in this I think my my
whole favorite recurring gag is the bits
with the dog because I love this [__]
like the dog they get it from the
quote-unquote pikies like the Irish
traveler group because they give him a
dog with every deal I guess so they get
this dog and the dog pretty much
immediately like swallows a squeaky toy
so like for the rest of the movie like
every time it's not like I like that
it's a gag but it's not like overdone
you know what I mean and they don't like
call a lot of attention to it but like
whenever the dog is in a scene and
whenever he like kind of moves or barks
he kind of squeaks a little bit which I
think is really funny and then I like
too that the that him eating the squeaky
toy near the beginning of the movie is
kind of like pays off later on when he
actually does eat the diamonds like it's
like foreshadowing you know what I mean
so I thought that was really good and
that whole scene too where they find out
that the dog took the diamond and
swallowed it and then they're like so
then Dennis farina's character is like
telling uh Bullet Tooth Tony to cut open
the dog and he won't do it like even
though he'll kill people like nothing
but they tell him like he's like well
get go inside the dog he's like what do
you go inside the dog is that a tin of
baked beans and it's like he won't
[__] do it I think that's a I think
that's a typical [__]
the thing though I think that too that's
why it's like it's funny it's funny but
it's like you understand it though
because it's like yeah they kill people
but they're other gangsters yeah you
know the dog didn't do anything and the
dog is innocent it's kind of a western
thing you know dogs and cats are pets
and horses you know they're they're pets
that'd be like killing a child yeah you
know so and yeah and I think people even
criminals do kind of think about that
the same way yeah so that's why I kind
of thought that was funny but I like I
don't know who they are I like that too
because Dennis Farina absolutely did not
give a [__] he just wanted to cut the
dog open and get the diamond out because
it's an 84 karat diamond but I love that
like the the British guy was like no
like I'm not [__] deal with that he's
not a tin of baked beans
um Tyler the guy said the difference is
in England you mainly get actors and
America you mainly get movie stars yeah
I hope that makes sense the way I phrase
it and I mean you know we do have a lot
of like actor actors here too but it
just does seem like
as a whole it doesn't get I think it
doesn't get taken as here who makes it
in Hollywood is very different from
Who's acting yeah yeah that's a that's a
scene unto its own it's like a [__]
popularity contest and
you know there's internal politics going
on and there's behind the scenes party
and in relationships and [__] it's just
just because a person's in on in a movie
doing a role doesn't mean that that's
the best person for that job that's just
something you got in there
because of the director or the producer
or whatever you know politics
Zach says when I see what Christian Bale
does to himself for movies I guess um I
legit wonder what health issues he's
gonna have later in life and how much
his doctor must hate him yeah especially
after he did I was thinking after he did
The Machinist because he essentially I
can't remember like what weight he went
down to if you haven't seen The
Machinist please see it holy crap it's
like I don't think you've seen it either
but that was when Christian Bale like
basically like starved himself like he
all he said all he had ate was like gum
and coffee and he starved himself down
to like nothing he looked like a [__]
living skeleton it's horrifying and uh
I'm you know I'm sure they enhanced it
with makeup and stuff but you can tell
that that's [__] real and then like
later on didn't he play [__] um Dick
Cheney yeah in Vice it looked just like
and he he did and he gained a bunch of
weight for that and I was like oh my God
yeah now I was thinking that too I was
like holy [__] you're a doctor you look
just like Jenny saddo just liked him
acts just like him he passed his Dick
Cheney it was crazy yeah that was a good
movie actually I think we saw that in
the theater said I told Tom I'll take
her break from sending movies for a
month or so so you can do some horror
movies Jenny well thank you that's it
well but you did send casino and we
still got to do that but that's I don't
mind that because like I [__] love
Casino man
yeah
um because I definitely have been
wanting to do that that was one that I
had on the list because I [__] love
that movie and I haven't seen it I might
have seen that in the theater too
um Tyler said you could also he also
could fit to play Batman yeah yeah but
so just like the the [__] that he that
man does to his body is [__]
incredible I thought he was a good
Batman and some people [__] got upset
about the voice that he would put on in
Batman yeah and when I first heard it I
thought I liked it
the more I heard it I was like that's a
little over top you know but uh it yeah
it is but not my much it's like it's
slight yeah it's it's good uh those I
love those movies yeah
it doesn't matter if they're
entertaining you know
yeah I get it I mean and sometimes too
like I think begins with [__] my
favorite one I thought that was the best
one yeah I like them
those were those were the good Batmans
yeah but uh but yeah so anything else
that you would like to talk about in
regards to snatch
um it's
it's just it's just a good British
gangster movie it's very entertaining uh
it's got violence in it it's got a lot
of humor in it
um yeah there's some funny [__] yeah
if you've ever seen a Quentin Tarantino
movie and liked that that's very
American this is kind of like a British
equivalent to that like it's very very
it's very British very British very
British um I needed subtitles
I don't know what the [__] they were
talking about and he had to ask me like
um a couple of times like if they if
they use like a like a slang term yeah I
was like what the hell is that
they're doing stuff like
in the
dropping H's off the beginning of
[__] words yeah what the [__] they
don't um they don't do that everywhere
like um that's I mean that these are
said in London so that's a cockney thing
yeah like some of the other
um accents do that too but some of them
like hit the H really hard but a lot of
them do kind of drop it yeah
but um yeah so yeah the same language of
course yeah it's just that uh sometimes
you don't know what the noun was
[Laughter]
and I was like what the [__] is a pike
so well they did explain it after later
on yeah so
the noun but you kind of get the gist of
what they're talking about and over time
you go oh okay I think I know what
they're talking about now what a pike he
is but she told me what it was I would
have figured it out though yeah um but
it's just not that just other things it
was like you know what [__] are they
talking about
and then he goes oh okay that's what
they're talking about okay just [__]
like that you know I kind of laughed
actually I think this was from Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels but when
one of them he gave this big long spiel
and then at the end he said and Robert's
your mother's brother and that like made
me laugh really really hard and because
that's like that's like a two-layered
flag because the slang is actually and
Bob's your uncle which I don't even know
where that came from but um but that's
something that they say a lot so I like
that they were taking that already uh
kind of
weird slang and like putting another
layer of oh Robert's her mother's
brother I was like oh Bob's your uncle I
get it so like I said it's kind of like
and Cockney rhyming slang is kind of
like that too where it's like what
they'll do is they'll take a word that
is supposed to be you know like um I
don't know like stairs and they'll make
a phrase that's usually two words that
rhymes with that yeah I don't understand
it and then so then they'll just refer
to it but just by using the first word
I'm not explaining it that good
um
they did that in the last movie
they're in the car and they started
talking and the guys just said something
that didn't make any goddamn sense and
Jenny says uh what he meant was is this
because and it was he and it was a
sentence that rhymed with that yeah
cocky writings like yeah which is like a
it's a way uh some kind of old-fashioned
British way I don't know maybe it's not
even old-fashioned it's a British way
of getting away with saying something
you can't say it maybe somebody might
overhear you
so you say a sentence that rhymes with
the other sentence
now he did I did to me it didn't really
rhyme
sometimes it Rhymes in British English
but not in American English because we
pronounce things slightly different they
didn't use a lot of it in this I did
code I think it is kind of and I think
that's how it started out but I mean
it's not a code anymore because
everybody knows it but uh well not
everybody but I mean kind of everybody
over there like kind of knows but I
think the only British or Cockney
rhyming slang I heard in this one was I
think Bullet Tooth Tony said porcupies
at one point which means lies but
usually they would just say porkies you
know what I mean Pork Pies is what the
phrase is but they would just say
porkies and that means lies so do you
know you're telling me porkies that's
what they would say and I think that he
said another one too but I can't because
I remember like thinking of it but I
didn't I know I can't remember what it
is but that was just the first one that
came to mind I'm always like fascinated
by it that's why I'm always fascinated
by like British slang and stuff because
I think their slang is a lot more
creative than ours
um because they're they're super into
like word play and puns and all this
other kind of stuff and it's like really
interesting to me cause I'm really into
language yeah and [__] like that so it's
like it's not so it's a lot more
literate yeah you know so I find it like
a lot more interesting and like funnier
than our slang our slang is usually kind
of just like it's very much in your face
yeah not always I kind of feel like with
the Advent of internet slang it's kind
of gotten more creative I feel like
because it's more crowdsourced I guess
but American culture didn't play out
that way it's it's not Southern it
definitely wasn't Wild West you couldn't
do that you had to be careful what you
said and you had to be clear being plain
spoken was a way of keeping yourself out
of a lot of trouble so I think you deal
with an armed population all right
um if you're too witty
person especially if they've been
drinking
might consider might read into what you
said he insulted me and then they'd kill
you so you had to be real plain and
polite and you um
you could you don't want to say anything
that would have alternate
interpretations you could get hurt so I
don't think those cultures
American culture kind of prevented the
Cowboys said that you must ride shoot
straight and speak the truth that's
[__] basically so witty being witty
might be misinterpreted as lying
I mean it's just a cultural it's a
cultural thing yeah it was just I kind
of feel like you know if ever since well
[__] I was gonna say going back to Oscar
Wilde but I'm sure it was like way
before that but so wittiness or being
like well spoken was always something
that or having like a clever play with
words was always like something that was
more valued like over there you know
yeah
plus also America was always pretty much
uh a place where
class systems were kind of frowned upon
people didn't like being in other
classes
and showing off high degrees of
Education could get you hurt I think
that's another thing you go down to a
poor
say mining town and show off [__]
high literary skills in a bar they'll
beat you up you know
that's why they're all up in New York
well the thing about it though is that
some stuff like Cockney rhyming slang
and stuff like that is very much a
working class yeah that was the very
bottom up that sounded like something to
evade the police I think that's how it
started out it started out among kind of
like the criminal underworld where they
were just trying to make yeah it was
like a code where they were trying to
like use words yeah you know they do
that here too
yeah I mean [__] a lot of slang yeah
is a way of talking about a drug without
actually saying the word you know what I
mean uh
um a lot of gangster slang is like that
I don't know any of the new stuff but
back in the old days all you do is put
in a rap record and [__] a half of it
was like in code
yeah so it's the same cut it's the same
kind of thing I don't think it's quite
as different
as you know particularly something like
that which like I said very much came
from the working classes or the criminal
underclasses yeah uh Tyler the guy said
if sarcasm got you killed in the old
west and my ass would be dead in the
first five minutes yeah me too well
because that's the thing I just can't
you couldn't insult somebody unless you
were ready to [__] fight or you know
I mean I just can't help it like
sometimes I don't really mean to be a
smart ass but it's just kind of like
that's just how it comes out
because that's my whole family is like
that and it's just like that's just kind
of how we interacted with one another so
that's just kind of like everything I
say kind of comes out like that I can't
help it America was not Lawless even the
old west was not Lawless it's it's rates
of violence in towns were lower than
modern rates of violence
but outside of town on the Range there
wasn't any law out there it would be the
same as being at Sea like like in
international waters dudes did all kinds
of [__] and you had to
it was kind of like uh you had to play
cool out there you had to be a good
judge of character and you had to try to
get along with a lot of people there was
uh you know there was Indians out there
you could trade with but you could also
get killed by them you know
um
and the Indians would fight each other
and white dudes are fighting each other
and white guys and Mexican Cowboys were
fighting it just depending on where you
were
and but they also got along it was just
a mixture it was just chaos you know
just
depending on the situation but if you
were out there in the [__] field I
call it the field and now it is around
the range that's what they would call it
and you insulted somebody and he didn't
like it
they're no law enforcement and
everybody's got guns that dude [__]
kill you
just the way it was it's still kind of
like that look at some of those uh
modern westerns that some of these
people
send us uh you know there are a lot of
places in the United States that are
still kind of like the kind of like uh
you know they are in the wilderness so
it's going to be kind of an old west
kind of situation
yeah kind of well Mississippi was an
anarchy for [__] its whole existence
yeah yeah there's no cops well at least
not out in the middle of nowhere
but yeah so um anyway so this is this
was a [__] great movie I like I said
I saw this back when it came out and I
hadn't seen it again since then so I was
actually really excited that you sent it
because I've been wanting to revisit it
and like I said it was much funnier than
I remembered because I didn't I had
forgotten about all the stuff like with
the dog like eating the diamond and I
just like I forgot about all of the
little intricacies about the plot I
remembered Brad Pitt like being a boxer
and I kind of remembered that and I kind
of remembered some of the heist type of
stuff and I I also forgot too like how
everything came together at the end
which I really liked like how the all
the plot threads came together I really
like that which kind of happened in
lockstock too but I think it was like
more satisfying in this one in a way
that I'm not can't where I put my finger
on but um but yeah are you ready to uh
wrap it up yep all right so tomorrow is
Monday which means it's time for
haunting Mondays once again and we're
gonna be doing uh season five episode
ten and I think it is and it's called
death's door so that's the one that
we're going to be talking about tomorrow
also right after we finish up here I
actually did a video this weekend that I
just recorded and edited and I covered
the whole entire first season of Rod
serling's Night Gallery except for the
pilot that was like a different I made a
separate video about that like a long
time ago but I actually bought like all
the Night Gallery like the box set of
all three seasons so I actually watched
this first season which was six episodes
so it's like 17 stories and I did a
video about it today and it turned out
being like an hour and 20 minutes long
like after it was edited which I didn't
realize but okay so um but yeah so it's
all edited so I'm probably gonna put it
up
um you know in the next so it'll
probably be up like this evening
sometime and I'm putting that up over on
my scare Salon channel so if you don't
have us if you're not subscribed over
there then you need to go over and
subscribe uh over there and then you can
watch it but I'll probably post it I'll
post it on Facebook and um and uh like
on the in the YouTube Community Tab and
all that other kind of stuff like I
usually do so you know if you want to
see me talk about the first season of
Night Gallery for an hour and 20 minutes
then
you're in luck today you know what I
mean all right so uh have a good rest of
your Sunday evening you guys and thank
you for dropping by and we'll talk to
you guys again tomorrow night good night